believe it or not you're watching an
actual jet engine laid with a jam job
like James diaper from England hmm
now that's what I'm talking about jam
jar [ __ ] this idea could really take
off so how did James create his jam jar
jet time for our scientists to blow the
lid on this one this particular jet
engine here is called a pulse jet it has
no moving parts no turbines but it does
produce thrust pulsejets don't burn
continuously but proceed by a short
sharp bursts or pulses James puts his
fuel into the jam jar and then puts the
lid on the fuel starts to evaporate and
mixes with oxygen from the air inside
the jar and some of this mixture leaks
out the hole on the top when he puts a
layer to the top of the jar it ignites
the gas and causes it to expand rapidly
through the hole in the top giving us a
fiery noisy pulse when the pulse happens
gas is ejected out of the jar and this
means there's a partial vacuum in the
jar this partial vacuum leads to more of
the fuel evaporating and it also leads
to more air being sucked into the jar
and when the fuel and the oxygen from
the air flowing in mix they use the heat
from the previous pulse and that causes
a second pulse to light up this process
will continue happening over and over as
long as there's fuel or for as long as
the engine could sustain the heat and
pressure and in this case the engine is
made of glass so eventually it gives way
before the fuel runs out into glass
frames James has taken a jam jar taken
out the jam and replaced it with science